we're on problem 14 and it asks us what
is a solution to the inequality X minus
5 is greater than 14 well to do this
this is just like solving any well
equality or equation what we do to one
side we have to do the other side I
don't want to get rid of this minus 5
and the best way to get rid of a minus 5
is to add 5 so let's add 5 to both sides
of this equation so 5 plus and then a
plus 5 and then a 5 plus a minus 5
that's zero that's why we added the 5 in
the first place we're just left with an
X on that side we get X is greater than
14 plus 5 which is 19 and that's choice
B problem 15 the lengths of the sides of
a triangle are so that we have a
triangle and it tells us the lengths of
the sides are y y plus 1 and seven
centimeters they also tell us the
perimeter is 56 centimeters the
perimeter is equal to 56 centimeters
what is the value of y so the perimeter
of any shape is just the sum of the
sides right so y plus y plus 1 plus 7
right that's the distance around the
triangle and that is equal to the
perimeter which is equal to 56 let's see
we get y plus y is 2y plus 1 plus 7 is 8
is equal to 56 so you get 2y is equal to
is that 56 so if we subtract 8 from both
sides of this equation we get on the
left-hand side we just get 2y on the
right hand side 56 minus 8 that's 48
divide both sides by 2 and you get Y is
equal to 24 and that is choice a problem
16 problem 16 now what do they want us
to do I think this is what I should copy
and paste
okay now there they're telling us let me
pick a good color which number serves as
a counterexample to the statement below
so a counter example one an example that
shows that this isn't always true so the
statement is all positive integers are
divisible by two or three so we just
have to find a positive integer that is
not divisible by two or three by neither
2 nor 3 well 100 is divisible by 2 right
so that that just verifies or it's just
another example of a positive integer
that's divisible by one of these two so
it's not choice it's not a counter
example 57 it's not divisible by two but
it is divisible by three 19 times three
is 57 so it's not choice B 57 is another
positive integer that's divisible by 2
or 3 7 by 3 so it's not that 30 is
divisible by boat so that's definitely a
contour example but here we have 25 it's
a positive integer and it is neither
divisible by 2 nor 3 so it disproves the
statement so it is a counter example and
so the answer is D problem 17 problem 17
let me copy and paste this one copied it
that's pasted it all right what is the
conclusion of the statement in the box
below okay they say if x squared is
equal to 4 so if we know that x squared
is equal to 4 then we know and we know
this from algebra we could have solved
it that X is equal to minus 2 or 2 all
right so what is the conclusion of the
statement in the box below okay
I think I'm reading this too much this
is this is the condition and this is the
conclusion right there saying if this
has happened then we conclude that so
they're actually just asking us to label
it so right this is the conclusion then
X is equal to minus 2 or 2 I think
that's a bet I don't like that question
so much because you my admirer reaction
was okay if this is the whole statement
right what can I conclude from it right
and there's not a lot that I could
conclude from it unless they told me
that this indeed was true but anyway I
don't get too complicated they're just
saying that if this is true then we can
conclude this and they're actually just
saying what is the conclusion so what
part of this statement can we label as
the conclusion well that's the
conclusion so that's choice D I didn't
like that that was a little bit more
almost that was more meaning of words
than math but anyway problem 18 all
right let me copy and paste this one too
which of the following is a valid
conclusion to the statement okay so now
you see now there if a student is a high
school band member then the student is a
good musician so if you're in the high
school band high school band member then
you're going to be a good musician
that's what this says
and you know if you compare this to the
last question this is that could be
confusing right because a valid
conclusion so once again you know here
they're giving us a statement they wants
to come to some conclusion they might
have said what is the conclusion of this
statement right and then you said oh
student is a good musician but that's
not what they're asking they're saying
okay if this whole thing is a statement
if we know that this whole thing is true
if a student is a if they're in the high
school band then they're a good musician
right which I kind of wrote in shorthand
here they're asking okay if we know that
to be true which of these statements can
we conclude from that statement a says
all good musicians are high school band
members well no that doesn't tell us
that it doesn't say that all good good
musicians we could have you know the
good musicians could be this circle and
the high school band members would be a
subset of it right high school band and
this could be good musicians so right
all high school band members are good
musicians but there could be people out
here who are good musicians who aren't
high school band members so it's not
choice a a student is a high school band
member well no I mean high school does
high school band members they didn't
tell us that all of the students or high
school band members or the high school
band is composed comprised of all the
students
the student body might be like this
circle some of them might be in the high
school band some of them aren't and a
good musician some of them aren't and
aren't good musician so I mean you don't
know whether someone is a high school
band member just by being a student all
students are good musicians well once
again you know this could be an example
there could be people out here who are
students right where that could be the
the yellow could be students there could
be people who are students who aren't
good musicians right the statement
doesn't in any way constrain that so
let's get rid of that see all high
school band members are good musicians
well let's look at this Venn diagram I
mean that's they're almost like a state
of restating of what they already told
us all high school band members have to
be good musicians because they told us
if you're in the high school band then
you're good musician so it's almost like
repeating the same statement twice but
the answer is D problem 19 problem 19
let me erase this one this looks like
another one that I'm going to have to
copy and paste okay
copied it okay let me do a dark color
I'll do the chart below shows an
expression of valued for for different
values of X all right when X is equal to
1 x squared plus X plus 5 right 1 plus 1
plus 5 is 7 when X is equal to 2 then 2
squared plus 2 plus 5 is 11 fair enough
jeziah or Hosea I don't know how to
pronounce that concluded that for all
positive values of X x squared plus X
plus 5 produces a prime number okay
which value of x which value of Xers is
an example
serves as a counter example to prove
desires conclusion false
so a counter example says he says that
whenever I put any positive number here
I get a prime number here right we have
to say which one proves him false so
when if you put 5 there what does 5
squared is 25 plus 5 plus 5 and what is
that equal to that's equal to 35
so that's a counterexample right there
if X is equal to 5 I produce 35 which is
not a prime number not prime right so
clearly his statement his conclusion was
incorrect that when you put a positive
number here it doesn't always produce a
prime number that was his conclusion
this one isn't prime so the statement a
is a counter example or order the number
5 is a counter example here next problem
problem 20 ok this is one of those were
we have to pinpoint the incorrect step
John's solution to an equation is given
below for this step of real numbers to
which property of real numbers to John
use for step two ok so we don't even
have to look at step one we just have to
say ok how did he get from there to
there all right so to make this so when
you get look at this we say X plus 2
times X plus 3 is equal to 0 you're
saying some number right some number X
plus 2 times some other number X plus 3
is equal to 0 so that's like saying you
know some number times some other number
is equal to 0 so that means that one of
those numbers or both of them have to be
equal to 0 right because the only way to
get zeros if one of these are both of
these have to be equal to 0 and that's
where he gets this conclusion that
either X plus 2 has to be 0 or X plus 3
zero they're both 0 so let's see how
they what are they called multiplication
property of equality I don't even know
what that means 0 property of
multiplication this seems like the
closest one for me so far that anything
times 0 is 0 or for two things to be
multiplied to equal 0 at least one of
them has to be 0 and that's what this
can this is right here commutative
property of multiplication no that's not
a distributive property of
multiplication over addition no we're
not doing anything like that if we went
from this step to that step where we're
multiplying it that might have been
because you're really just doing the
distributive property but I want to
confuse you
yeah we're just saying that if two
numbers when you multiply them equal 0
one of them have to be equal to 0 and I
guess the label for that is the zero
product property prior product
property of multiplication anyway see in
the next video